Okay. So this is like something that like, I really wanna know.
So today I was at school and I walked, um,
in like the little village area, like, you know, I was just chilling.
I was doing my homework and I sat down to do my homework and this really fine
black man walked past me. Um, disclaimer, on black. But anyway,
so he was walk past me and I was like, he's.
I dunno some, I was like, yo disclaim, Ron black.
You know what it makes me think of?
It makes me think of the people who are always in YouTube comments, be like, uh,
news slash everyone. The girl in question's not black, she's biracial.
And they get all excited about making <laugh>
Of course, Obama didn't have black people. He's biracial,
raised by a white woman. <laugh> uh, news flash.
I'm each Ethiopia. He's.
Really cute. I'm not gonna talk to him anyway. But like in my head for a second,
I was like, he's really cute. And then I was like, oh, he's tall,
he's an athlete. Blah, blah, blah. And then, you know, I said to myself, I said,
this black man, probably don't even like black girls.
He probably doesn't even talk to black women.
Man. Sometimes I get so excited.
Sometimes looking piece of. I get so excited.
Cuz I pick videos because I know.
You knew exactly what the you was doing when you did that. When you picked that,
you knew exactly what the you, Hey bro, you want a film tonight? Yeah, sure.
Whatever you knew exactly what the you was doing.
Hey man, this is what, this, this is what happens when you,
when you care about someone, you curate things for <laugh>.
You don't care about me outta here.
But you know what I do care.
About must be the <laugh>.
That is
On the topic of this kind of behavior and this kind of thinking. I think,
I think what it,
what kind of peeves me about it is like sometimes as a black dude,
you can just be in this space, minding your business.
And this person has all this crazy inner dialogue and looks at you like your
garbage. And I'm like, yeah, I was just here. Yeah.
Don't even know me. No.
And you're convinced that I have all these terrible views.
And it's just weird to me that as someone who is marginalized,
you're going to do immediately the same thing to an individual who may not be
deserving of that. You know what this reminds me of,
this reminds me of when like dudes go up to a girl like, Hey baby, uh,
you want to get something due to right? And they're saying all this gross stuff,
even though it's not who they actually are,
they get a little bit of liquor in them and they act really goofy. Yeah.
And all it is, it's like a preemptive strike.
Like I already know you're gonna probably who I really am.
So let me just do this whole little Shara in this stupid dance.
So you don't even get to really reject me. It's the same idea.
This is all just self-preservation it's bad. It's not healthy.
And when I see it, I, I, I,
I just get disappointed in people and that's the same for this girl.
She's a beautiful black woman. You know what I'm saying? Yep. Right on my alley,
right. It up my type. Right.
And the idea that I could be walking down the street and this person is so
convinced that they're, you know,
that would probably be something that I'd be off putting to be like having to
deal with that. It's like,
that might be something that makes someone not want to deal with you.
So if you feel this way, you constantly think this way, address,
whatever you got going on inside.
So you don't take that negative of energy into your relationships and your
dynamics.
Because if you do that could be the reason why you miss out on really great
people. She's upset because she feels like black men,
marginalized black women, and have no interest in them. Right.
They have these preconceived notions about what black women are like.
And they're like, I hate them. So I'm gonna go for different women.
And then yeah. And but her,
without knowing the man in front of her has preconceived notions about what that
individual's like and what he's into.
And therefore they're going to move forward with that in her head.
So she's doing in a weird way. What a lot of black dudes do, which is like,
I already know who you are,
therefore I'm not gonna give you a shot the same way black men.
So some black dudes will be like black women are like this. So then I worth it.
She's doing the same thing to this man, this black,
man's probably not gonna be into me, he's into other stuff.
So I'm not even gonna open my, and there's an interesting cycle there.
I can't tell you how many times I've had women say, oh, apple,
you look like you're into white women.
Not knowing my dating preference whatsoever.
Not knowing how many times I've been shot my shot, black ladies,
and been turned out and I'm not jaded. I'm not mad. I'm open. I'm it is.
I'm always going to be.
But it's just interesting to me that there's all these preconceived notions that
people come into situations and oftentimes they're so wrong,
but here's the thing. It really just comes down to a very simple thing.
It's a self defense mechanism. I think you don't like me.
So I'm going to disqualify myself already.
So you don't even get the opportunity to reject me,
but you also will know what you miss out on you miss out on having an
opportunity at all. That's analogy.
There's a plenty of people out there that you probably disqualified that may
have actually been interested in.
But because you come in with so much of this negative energy to try to preserve
yourself, you stop yourself from having a lot of good connections in your life.
You know, mm-hmm <affirmative> and that's a sad,
sad cycle that I see repeating itself.
We have to stop running with these notions that this is like a, a common,
common, every day everywhere thing,
because the truth of the matter is 87% of black men are married to black women.
Mm-hmm <affirmative>
87% of black men are married to black women.
That doesn't mean that there aren't a group of them who prefer going out.
That doesn't mean that her son in love who don't have terrible,
but we also have to be careful to not make an overrepresentation
of these, of these phenomenons because we make them far worse than they are.
But what it ends up doing is actually exacerbates.
The very issue we think is so rampant.
And so mm-hmm <affirmative> I was gonna say,
if you feel like you don't get the shine that you deserve based off, you know,
what's not gonna help you, you coming in with negative energy,
it's not what you want to hear, but sometimes that's the truth.
And those are my thoughts. Uh,
but I'm gonna tell you why I'm triggered like that when like that happens,
the reason why all this happens and why I'm triggered like that and why I'm
like, I lose my sometimes.
And I roll my eyes and I leave is because it comes back to when I was a kid. It,
when I was a kid, uh, some of my bullies were teachers.
Some of my bullies were black people,
but some of the bullies that I had were black women. Okay.
I was not black enough. I was not man enough. I was, I was this, sorry,
I used the word, but that's the word that they use. All right.
I don't know how many times I, I, I heard that, that, that, and I was not. Ah,
and I ain't just, he, this and that.
And most of the time was really just because I had respect for them.
Cause I didn't try anything on them when they were like necessarily in their
most vulnerable position or stuff like that. You understand?
So whenever someone tells me, yeah, you probably just, yeah,
you probably is like white women. First.
It brings me back to you calling me not black enough.
You don't even know me. And then you're just demoing. Yeah. He's like that.
He's one of those, a trait. He's he's that?
It brings me back to that time where they were my biggest bully when I was just
not enough. Not manly at enough. Not a man enough.
Not none of that enough until I have a woman. I have a wife.
I have, I have a girlfriend and she had parents to be white and oh, oh, you got,
you got a girl, you got a girlfriend. You oh word. Oh, I,
oh, she's probably white. And I'd be like, yes she is. But she's not,
I don't go out with her because she's white.
I go out with her and she happens to be white because I could be dating other
people, other races and everything and stuff. You know what I mean?
I didn't select her because of her race. But it brings me back to that. Oh, I,
oh yeah. You, it must be because yeah, cuz you're not. Yeah.
You're not really a black man. You're not really black, black.
So you're going to go out with your own kind of Mawas over there.
You know what I mean? That gets to me because I'm like, yo, you know, you're,
you're marginalized and you're gonna marginalize your own kindness. Just stupid.
And I told you that time when I was in a chat, I was like on,
I was on this platform called uh,
clubhouse where I thought it was really just PIs.
But apparently it's a platform where people talk and I was in this room, right.
This was black room. And people was talking mad about, about white people.
And there was this dude that was calling him. That was,
that was calling white people, snow roaches and like that.
And I was like, bro,
you're so if my white wife is a snow Roach,
and you're that makes you a cockroach,
not that's your definition. I mean, you have to be petty for it.
I had to be petty for, but I didn't even say that. I was just like, I was like,
you know what? Hey,
I'm just gonna shut the up and stay quiet about this because I can't win.
You know, I can't win BR the amount of time, the amount of time, go ahead,
get channels to a lot of things. Okay. It's a lot of things. Okay.
It's first and foremost, just in general, disclaimer,
just forget that she's a black girl. Okay. Just the fact that she's a woman,
that's how women flirt.
They get these ideas and they go by them and they run with that.
I don't know what it is about women and fantasy or what they think. Oh,
he is probably like this and like that, oh, he doesn't like this.
And he's like that this got, have like, God that wakes up in the morning,
take two coffees, like coffee.
And they go with these whole things and schemes and they run with
it. Mm-hmm <affirmative> yeah. I didn't like how he made you feel,
how it made you feel. Well, he looks like this and he looks like that.
And that to me means this because my ex-boyfriend really like he had that.
So it, you haven't even talked spoken to the dude.
You just go about this whole fantasy about how things are supposed to be
because, uh, no. Oh man, you triggering me. You piece of.
Cause you go about all these tangent. You go about all these tangent about, oh,
I know what this is. This is, oh, for foremost, he's a Leo.
So Leo's are like this and like that. So they're,
he must be like this and that and that. So it must be like that.
So therefore what's his descend again? What, what, um,
what time were you born? Uh, nine 15 in the morning.
So nine 15 in the, it is a Senate is a Virgo.
So you know that doesn't work. And the run with that, with that whole scheme,
without even talking to the dude, there's a whole thing that goes on day, month.
You know the goes of the bitter. That's what sister right there.
The ghost of what the are you talking about? <laugh> it's like the whole,
and then she runs with it.
That's even before she is a disclaimer, black girl.
And then you have to take into conservation. The disclaimer.
Now you have to take the traumas of the person, all the traumas.
So they already go about doing a whole bunch of stories about the person that
they are looking at now mm-hmm <affirmative> while there's a trauma,
you have to take incarceration. The trauma, not only the trauma as being a,
a woman, but a trauma as being a black woman. And yes,
there's some men out there that do not date black women,
but they gonna go out there, be like, Ugh.
And just make this whole story and be like, I'm probably not gonna date him.
Cause he probably didn't even like black girls. Yeah. He doesn't, he doesn't.
Whew. We can, we can.
Get deep into this.
He probably don't even think twice about black girls at all
whatsoever.
And this is something that has been happening to me since high school.
And I'm so tired of having to wonder whether or not black men,
even like black girls. It's so disheartening.
What's been happening to you since you were in high school,
you making up stories about black people, black men,
whether they are it's like, you don't even know. Yes, they are some,
but what's been happening. Uh, it doesn't like black or, oh,
he doesn't like black girls. Oh,
he that's been happening to you then it didn't happen to you.
You made it happen to yourself. And the thing that happened is that like,
I'm not gonna sit here and act like there's there are no black men that
do not have these thoughts. Like there are no man.
That's not what I'm trying to do. I know there are some out there,
her and it's just, Ugh, it's just, it's been a while. And I,
since I have the conversation with one of them,
but when I have a conversation with like, yeah,
black men are like black women are like this black women are like that.
I'm like, Ugh, you're the reason they hate me so much. You know what I mean?
You, you like this phenomenon exists.
I'm not gonna go out there and be like, it doesn't,
I'm not cuz it does exist. And I understand where,
why she has that train of thought. Like she's not,
I'm not gonna go out and be like, she's crazy.
It's not even what I'm trying to do because she does have a point.
There are some men that do think like that. Right.
I understand where I hurt is from that's where whenever I walk New York with my,
my girlfriend, which she's white and I walk with New York,
I hear all sorts of comments coming from black women. Not even knowing me,
not even knowing what I like, you know? And I hear all the comments.
I don't say. And I said that before. Cause I know where the hurt is from.
I understand. So I'm not gonna go out there and be like, yo, shut the up. Nah,
no, I let them talk. Cause I understand. I get it. I get where it's from.
When you played the tape, I said tape. That's how old I am.
When you played the video. I was like, Ooh, okay.
Who's this by the I was did. I was like, oh. Alright,
Hey, what's up girl? Who's this? Yeah, who's this right?
And then she opened her mouth. She like, I was that cool. Right? And I'm like,
yeah, cool. What happened? What happened is cool. Tell me about,
I saw this beautiful black man mm-hmm <affirmative> and then what.
Happened, shorty? I'm pretty sure he is. Uh, just,
it's just your insecurities the same way guys might come out here and be like,
oh she's a beautiful woman. She's gotta be a. Right? It's the same idea.
Same thing. Same. It's the same thing. So, so you guys gotta manage that.
You guys gotta manage that and it's unfair to the black dude who was just
existing for you, you to put all of this on him. So just be mindful of that.
And that's pretty much all I really have. You got anything else you wanna say?
No. Right. Well that's it guys. Hey, if you guys are liking today's video,
leave a like comment. Right? We appreciate it. Helps out with the algorithm.
It takes two seconds. Just go do it.
So,
oh.